walk him to this video a 15 minute game
what what else is there Dutch hmm no not
the Dutch mom I should have played the
Dutch really again the London system hmm
well at least i'm very flexible now
against the Saudi Bishop f4 maybe with
c5 okay that's a that's more of a
fighting choice let's um let's see
attack the center and so it takes so
giving me a pretty nice central control
ok my f porn is missing but this is not
like a boring position that you
sometimes get when the other side is
playing this London system opening yeah
just knight c6 or is there something
more concrete even and I don't think so
on yeah 96 is okay it's always something
that you need to check if there is a
bishop out on f4 and g5 and III is being
played the diagonal a 5-2 e12 the King
can sometimes be tricky with a check on
a five or sometimes queen bee six
becomes very interesting attacking the
b2 pond and somehow forcing matters but
I didn't think I'm a tournament was
really am possible here okay Queen still
if I go Queen f5 now it's no no big idea
already behind that the real question
here is should I
should I go Bishop d6 I think this is a
good way to develop it probably will
provoke him him capturing himself which
helps me to get the Queen into play and
prepare short castles yeah theoretically
speaking he can also go Bishop g3 or
Bishop g5 but not really expecting that
bit of g3 is not not terribly bad though
certainly move that white can play
yeah at the end he he just took it okay
yeah I always thought that 93 might be
answered by deform directly i'm grabbing
the initiative ok of course night to the
night coming to be five is the issue so
probably I should start with castling
yet and now maybe deform this this could
be an IDM apply default ET for cd4 night
beehive I have queen before check this
should be quite ok d4 Knight B 528 ed
for a 6s the the other line that needs
to be checked so it's playable but
certainly play a bomb okay but I don't
need to do that I can also play and a
bit more conservative fashion I can also
just do this let's say b6 Bishop e7
rookie eight these kind of moves on d 8
ok so did I miss attacked again on d5
Bishop c4 moves like this I don't think
so really
yeah maybe he's trying to do that this
was some also an idea without b6 being
played just okay
there should be six i guess i can go on
IG five
by g5 rook the aid well this should be
okay for me I mean it's there ready to
be honest I wasn't totally sure about 90
x g5 instead of Bishop c4 right still
I'll I have a hard time to believe it
but cages Cass lot okay is it the dry
yeah just let's do that that that really
attacks the bishop so wow why I don't
think this is any good this is just a
one move attack but it does not lead to
anything um you know I'd like to go here
actually because there's an ID for this
is an interesting way to directly give
get get an attack myself and by now in
this this has lost time really okay you
know it just takes you for
what is the point where the queen is
hanging white resigns yeah and this was
some interesting from a technical point
of view mmm but it seems that there is
no no real decisive tactic Jack this is
in fact not totally clear but I can take
here yeah the problem is that the the
movie form is not not really working I
actually thought this is this is
impossible yeah this is overwhelming
yeah black black is winning outright and
GF that's basically the same look at
this that's a that's a deadly attack
okay and here this is still not working
if you cannot take on d5 know which you
cannot obvious of c-4 it's it's also not
leading to anything then taking on d5 is
a bad idea I think you probably should
just just Castle him black is somewhat
more comfortable already because of the
central control but nothing that should
win quickly and here we are getting
getting close to the point where it did
it it gets a bit to be a problem and
probably aware here yeah and then I'll
probably just go deform 94 is also
interesting immediately threatening this
but ok can peek and play this and that's
not totally clear do you defy is another
idea just pushing the deep on this
already and 23 is very dangerous and I'm
not not a good position and adhere we're
all might be five is just losing time I
don't mind to get the Queen here if you
look at this for example there should be
2 a-6 retreats and this is also in the
mix but yeah d3 not chips lad g4 that's
a terrible position he lost so much time
yeah well this I can I can just take it
end and that's it winning winning a
piece yeah it's it's very yeah it's a
very good idea normally if if you meet
someone who's playing this opening to
relatively quickly try to get them out
of the comfort zone by am by direct and
and sharp plane and well c 5 is not
terribly sharp but at least it
immediately forces some concession with
ease resi 3 or some some commitment you
played d5 surprisingly enough it's
important that for example here with e6
that you fight in the center I don't
really like to play move like windy 6 cm
it's a theoretically sound but still
white can can play something like that
going for for for sacrifice greenbee to
Bishop d2 and then II form coming this
position could also rise from the temp
our scheme from bosque with quite a
serious compensation but just attacking
with e6 is certainly fine and
he prolly should play c4 which is a
somewhat weird position it's like it
been known you with the bishop here but
I don't think that this should be a be
bad for white why not hmm okay yeah
thanks for watching